welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
medical cannabis pharmacogenomics and
drug drug interactions it is presented
by Jhon Marku PhD the co-founder chief
operations officer and director of
experimental pharmacology and behavioral
research at the International Research
Center of cannabis mental health my name
is Judy O'Rourke and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars so before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Marc who I will
now turn the presentation over to him
hello thank you today we will be
discussing medical cannabis
pharmacogenomics and drug drug
interactions and perhaps one of the most
important things you will learn from
this presentation is is on the opening
slide and that's my email address we're
going to talk about a lot of research
and a lot of things you might not have
heard about how THC and other
cannabinoids from the cannabis plant
interact with the human body and you're
going to have questions so what I would
like to talk about first is who we are
what is the
institute the International Research
Center on cannabis and mental health and
what are we doing and then I'll go into
pharmacogenomics examples of how you
test for this as well as discussing some
drug drug interactions with cannabinoids
that we might be able to avoid with with
this and I'm also happy to take any
questions about THC CBD and terpenes on
during the Q&A or by email so at our
Institute we have three goals which is
research education and advocacy we
advocate for safe and standardized
cannabis products as this is a public
health issue we're focused on education
around mental health clinicians and
other people who offer therapy and we
focus on cannabis mental health issues
and well-being I will share some of our
research projects that were engaged in
and how pharmacogenomics is playing a
role in helping to develop those studies
as we try to bridge the gap between
what's being done in the lab and
community and the health profession
don't pry the issues in cannabis
research have to do with the clinical
research being mostly focused on
physical illnesses most research on
mental health has been focused in a
basic research setting with animal
models but one of the most common things
patients report using cannabis for the
treatment of mental health symptoms such
as anxiety PTSD and other issues but
largely mental health clinicians view
cannabis uses of pathology and research
in industry and university is often
disconnected from the community and the
mental health practice issues and
community focus research can help remove
some of the ivory tower or political and
for profit product motivation and so we
focus on community-based research and
that there are some disconnects between
when someone is recommended or
prescribed a cannabis product and then
when they go out and they get treatment
or therapy from a separate health
professional a lot of popular topics
being studied in cannabis as well as by
earns to include piste PTSD Oh
and drug abuse and autism as well we
also have an interest in traumatic brain
injuries anorexia sexuality and
well-being and sexual function as a
common side effect of a lot of
antidepressants have an effect on sexual
function we're also interested in
looking at anxiety depression menopause
and other secondary gains from cannabis
treatment regarding education we have
recently completed a funded study
assessing the knowledge gap for mental
health clinicians in cannabis we found
that there was a lack of agreement on
differences between healthy use and
abuse of cannabis most of the health
professionals we interviewed had
recommended cannabis for treatment of
physical conditions not a lot of mental
health issues what the more some of the
most revealing things were that most
were uneducated or receive no formal
education or accredited education about
the endocannabinoids system and its
impact on mood many felt unsure about
cannabis effect on future drug use such
as many clinicians still believe that
the Gateway theory holds true that
cannabis causes people to use other
drugs which has been debunked by such
agencies as the DEA and other
institutions and they also saw that
there was a risk for developing
schizophrenia despite a lack of evidence
supporting these ideas and many of the
health professionals knew little about
dosing biphasic effects composition of
the plant as well as the impact from
different methods of consumption
regarding advocacy we believe it's safe
and standardized products we see that as
a public health issue that is really
important so in the past a lot of policy
has dictated research and standards
around cannabis and I think that there
is an obligation to start to have
science inform these policies and help
guide research
you know patients should be able to
access standardizing safe products and
mental health clinicians can encourage
their patients to use these safe and
legal products affordability is also an
issue for many patients who cannot
afford cannabis as it's not yet covered
by insurance in the United States when
it comes to treating a lot of drug abuse
disorders or drug use disorders you know
abstinence often fails and harm
reduction is the key there and so we
really are trying to create data that
should help to dictate and inform policy
another one of our projects is the new
hep x we've launched a fun educational
podcast internet show with some renowned
comedians and entertainers in New York
that have worked on everything from the
Chappelle show to David Letterman and
the late night show so if you're
interested in more of a long-form
discussion about cannabis and its issues
you can check that out so we don't do
this work alone we have a lot of
research partners and affiliations
including affiliation with NYU the
University of Michigan the University of
Saskatchewan the the cannabis chemistry
subdivision of the American Chemical
Society and groups like lab roots helped
to give us a platform to help discuss
these topics we also have agreements
with athletes for care and participate
in Thomas Jefferson's cannabis committee
that helps to fund research studies
we're active in the media you can read
interviews with us in nature and science
magazine as well as the British Medical
Journal and we've had some recent
articles published on project CBD
Prevention magazine as well as terpenes
and testing and we're doing a special
issue in the journal of clinical social
work that is focused on cannabis
research and that should be published
over the summer
so just real quick just to let you guys
know one of our studies that is funded
and nearly completed is a
quality-of-life survey looking at the
impact of cannabis on professional
athletes and this is expected to be
completed over the summer we have
completed we're almost done with a study
on knowledge and attitudes of cannabis
among mental health clinicians data
collection ends May 20 May 29 and some
of the data has already been submitted
for publication we are working with
local dispensaries in New York State to
study veterans with PTSD in a pilot
study where there is a guaranteed supply
of standardized products and looking at
how interventions such as psychotherapy
and education can impact cannabis use
and its effects on veterans with PTSD
and the data collection we'll be
beginning this summer in 2019 we're also
looking at a skin cream study for the
treatment of different pain conditions
and right now we're looking at starting
the study at the end of summer and we
recently just got funded for a Bodega
study a product safety study on New York
recently had banned a lot of CBD infused
products and edibles but they're still
widely available at a number of stores
yet there are no testing requirements
for these products so we're going to be
buying about a hundred products against
across five different categories and
getting them tested for not just potency
but also heavy metals and potentially
pesticides as well
one study we're also raising money for
to is to look at how THC and CBD
products affect driving and visual
processing looking at current products
in the markets and how that interacts
with pharmaceutical drugs that people
are taking so we're hoping to get this
study funded by the end of the year and
start getting people in do driving
simulators
so now on to genetics and genomics of
cannabis so a lot of times that people
think of pharmacogenomics or
personalized medicine they start to
think of variations in the genes that
encode the endocannabinoid system the
receptors and things like that that's
not what pharmacogenomics is that's a
separate field of study called
pharmacogenetics pharmacogenomics is
actually looking at our drug
transporters or drug metabolizing
enzymes these are known as the CIPS the
cyp enzymes predominantly in the liver
that metabolize all the drugs that we
consume and as you might imagine there
are many drugs which compete at these
enzymes which can alter their onset and
their kinetics so the reason that we
want to look at pharmacogenomics is that
each drug therapeutic substance has a
therapeutic index that determines how
easily a drug can be dosed to achieve
efficacy while avoiding side-effects if
the target range the narrow therapeutic
index there can be a lot of trial and
error and one of the strategies is dosed
tration which is slowly raising the dose
until the ideal balance between efficacy
and tolerability is reached and right
now a lot of patients go through a long
trial and error phase with different
types of products and different
varieties of cannabis and I believe that
pharmacogenomics can help reduce that
time and that money that's spent on that
trial and error period so there are two
major pharmacal actually
pharmacologically active compounds from
cannabis we'll discuss one is THC the
predominantly psychoactive component on
the plant and CBD which is also a very
interesting compound now the sensitivity
to both of these drugs is highly
variable between individuals for example
what's an efficacious dose in one person
can be non tolerated dose in another
and this requires a trial and error
period to find out what potential ratio
or individual amount of these substances
will work best so some of the sources in
responding to a drug have to do with the
kinetics it is the dose and the drug
concentration how are you absorbing it
how are you metabolizing it how fast is
it clearing out of your system there's
also the dynamics is the relationship
between how much drug is there and its
effect on a receptor at a very very you
know small level how is it interacting
with cells and it's its efficacy there
but when it comes to the bioavailability
and clearing the drug and it
metabolizing it we're talking about a
pass through the liver and this largely
applies to orally consumed products now
the most important enzyme family is
cytochrome p450 this is a large family
of liver enzymes that most
pharmaceutical drugs and cannabinoids
are processed through so there is a huge
variability in this enzyme between
populations you can have over a tenfold
difference between individuals and this
the the resources of variability and how
these enzyme works have largely to do
with two things one the drugs that are
there competing for it well as the
genetics what type of enzymes do you
have do you have the enzymes that work
really fast or do you have enzymes that
works really slow people inherit copies
of these and they can be combinations of
you know rapid metabolizers or regular
metabolize or slow metabolizers and
we'll show some examples of what happens
when you have two drugs competing at the
same set a little later on so for many
drugs that are distinct populations of
individuals with varying metabolizing
capacity
so in this little graph on the right you
can see this sort of breakdown and
obviously certain types are rare that
others the poor metabolizers tend to be
getting too bad copies let's just say
for conceptual purposes of one of these
sips this is fairly rare compared with
getting one good copy and one bad copy
so we we have this wide range of
ultra-rapid metabolizers extensive
metabolizers intermediate metabolizers
and poor metabolizers and as you can
imagine that will change how you respond
to a drug what type of dose can be
efficacious versus which one will not be
so if you're a poor metabolizer chances
are a small amount of a drug that goes
to that sip will be in your blood longer
circulating around and being active
longer because when you metabolize
things that's when they break down and
begin to be except severe side effects
the National Institute of Health has put
out a statement saying pharmacogenomics
is the studies of how genes affect a
person's response to drugs combines
pharmacology and genetics to develop
effective safe medication doses that
will be tailored to a person's genetic
makeup there are a number of clinical
trials looking at pharmacogenomics right
now at various genes and how they affect
a response to cannabinoids such as THC
versus CBD and we see I was able to find
about five studies that are currently
active funded that are looking at
certain drug transporters drug
metabolizing enzyme and the effect
they're going to become more and more
important so let's look at some of the
practical information behind this so one
version of a septa 2c9 type 3
polymorphism if we look at in vitro that
is in basic research assays on this this
is very
creation causes a significant reduced
enzyme activity so what that means is
that THC for example is going to be
around a lot longer and I'll potentially
a lot more active then if you don't have
that variant so on the left you see the
type one and the red bar it's getting
cleared right away out of the systems
getting metabolized you see on the right
that it is not so what this basically
showing is that this can increase plasma
levels you know just to talk from a
conceptual standpoint this is another
study confirming the previous work in
human being so participants who had the
type 3 genotype at three four threefold
higher THC levels compared with the
other group and you can see that
represented in blue versus green versus
red in the graph so just conceptually
let's say you are a legal cannabis
patient you might actually have higher
blood levels of THC in your system than
someone else which could be potentially
not so good if you get pulled over and
they administer a roadside sobriety test
whereas if you were a type one
metabolizer it might be well below the
cutoff and detection limit but it also
means that it might you might
potentially want to think about smaller
doses of things like THC because your
body is really maximizing its use it's
going to be there longer and might be
having longer effect a longer duration
of effect so in it this is indeed been
shown that this particular type 3
version of 2c9
increases the aural effects so you know
dose reduction is not necessarily on
foreign held THC but for oral THC this
seen this particular sip to c-93
definitely seems to increase the effects
of oral teetsi and that can come in too
could be an important thing to know if
you're coming up with a dosing strategy
or administration strategy for these
drugs now there are lots of different
routes of administration for
cannabinoids I'll talk about three real
quick one is inhaled there's oral and
sublingual so when you inhale cannabis
products such as through a vaporizer
you're not getting a lot of sniffing
can't pass through the liver
you do have sip enzymes located in your
periphery that will break down the drugs
but PGX
dosing pharmacogenomics dosing guidance
is needs also to be focused for specific
routes of administration and largely
what we're talking about here is in the
middle here the oral administration
edibles pills and things like that
sublingual is a great strategy for
avoiding first metabolism and drug drug
interactions in the liver but much of it
can be swallowed if it's not absorbed
under the tongue properly so we're gonna
talk and I think this will be the sort
of the last part of this presentation
talking about cannabinoid drug drug
interactions and doing this this
research and gap it was quite surprising
to find out some things like CBD when
taken orally competes with the same
liver enzymes as do as 60% of
prescription drugs on the market and
that may be leading to some side effects
we'll talk about the difference between
cannabinoids being victims of drug drug
interactions and perpetrators of those
drug drug interactions so there there
are different types of drug drug
interactions so there are when it
cannabinoid is a victim of a drug drug
interaction this is when cannabinoid
levels are changed by the presence of
another drug the drug is altering the
effects if you will of THC or CBD now
cannabinoids can also act as
perpetrators they can cause changes in
levels of another drug there's also
pharmacodynamic drug
interactions where both drugs contribute
to overlapping side-effects victim and
perpetrator don't apply here but an
overlapping side effect might be
sedation or increasing appetite or
something like that so there are a lot
of gaps in our knowledge about
cannabinoids and drug drug interactions
when they're taken orally
there's abilities but a lot of this
information is extrapolated from in
vitro drug metabolism studies that is a
petri dish test tube experiments as well
as animal studies we do have some data
available office which we will look at
but from these clinical studies what's
interesting is the drug drug
interactions was not the primary
objective of the study they just sort of
stumbled across it so here's an example
where cannabinoids are victims of drug
drug interactions so strong sip 3a4
inhibitors include a lot of these
plethora myosins ketoconazole and other
protease inhibitors these are very
commonly prescribed drugs when you look
at th see there's a 1.8 fold increase in
the presence of these inhibitors and an
11 hydroxy THC which is the liver
metabolites of THC someone take a THC
product orally and goes into the liver
and it's turned into 11 hydroxy THC
which is a bit more potent it's
considered to be a bit more potent than
regular old THC the levels and the blood
increased three and a half fold over the
cannabinoid alone and likewise CBD is
also affected saying almost a two-fold
increase and the amount in the blood
when administered with a drug that can't
inhibit this liver enzyme so like I said
THC is a potent active metabolite and
again this has been shown in research
that when is administered IV is a
significantly stronger intoxicating
effect
and an 11 hydroxy is only formed in
significant quantities after THC is
consumed orally so if you have a drug
that is increasing the amount of eleven
hydroxy THC that could become an issue
potentially terminal aids can also be
perpetrators of drug drug interactions
gnarrk Lobos am or Club Azam which is a
benzodiazepine often having strong
sedative properties often used in
epilepsy it's it's the levels of that
can significantly increase with the
presence of CBD and this could become an
issue if you know the drug is not
getting metabolized is around longer
having a stronger effect that can lead
to potentially more side effects or
other complications as well what is
interesting is THC can affect the muscle
relaxant baclofen so um on their own
there wasn't much of a sync objective
psychoactive up on the tube were
combined this drug actually produced a
significantly stronger subjective psycho
active effect according to participants
in the study so there is good news
direct-to-consumer pharmacogenomics
testing is increasingly available
similar to 23andme and other groups
navigator genomics there's a bunch of
groups that are offering this service I
think it's really simple it's
non-invasive evolves you know this
testing can be done quite simply with a
mouth swab and genetic analysis and now
we're starting to implement this into
our studies because what we've been
seeing with one of our partner groups
partners in health and well-being they
do about 16,000 patient visits a year
with clinicians and if a patient's over
45 they're on average of six
pharmaceutical drugs and so in studies
you may want to be able to identify
or help predict or avoid drug drug
interactions negative side-effects or
perhaps be able to explain those if they
are experienced by individuals and the
cost has dramatically dropped since this
technology was invented which is really
helping to make it sort of seamlessly
integrated as an option in clinical
study so in summary I strongly believe
that pharmacogenomics could be used to
help predict individual cannabinoid
metabolism helping to personalize
cannabis products for patients the
predictions from pharmacogenomic data
could speed up the trial and error
period improve dose rate raishin and
therapy outcomes drug interactions and
other factors such as diet must be taken
into account when you're either
designing clinical studies or using
cannabis products as a medicine it's
important to remember that cannabis is
greater than the sum of its parts
THC and CBD are interactions reduce side
effects and increase efficacy THC by
itself is kind of a lousy drug with some
side effects CBD and terpenes can help
reduce those side effects such as
intoxication and impairment genomic and
genetic responses influence THC and CBD
effects and and I hope this presentation
has been informative please feel free to
email any of your pharmacogenomic
questions to j Marku at IRC CMH org and
for any those of you who want to know
where some of this information comes
from here are some handy-dandy
references I'm happy to share these with
folks and for more information about the
Institute research opportunities please
contact our CEO Jane Roberts at Jay
Roberts at IRC CMH org thank you thank
you dr. Marc who for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next time bye